i'm here with professor lawrence baker
at stanford medical school and uh what
what we're going to talk about now is i
just the overview of the health care
system what is the health care system
yeah and who's in it and who's in it and
what are they doing i think i could give
a go at it go for it and then correct me
okay and expose my ignorance okay
so so clearly you know you have your
kind of your providers that those would
be your your doctors and and nurses and
all the rest i mean hospitals all kinds
of people okay so everyone who's
providing health care so that's right
over there so that's hospitals doctors
pharmacies all the rest
and then they're they're providing the
health care to someone yeah so those
would be the patients let me do that in
another color yep
call them patients yeah some sometimes
you get details like you know people
become patients after they need health
care but some people just have a
question they're not really patients
they're just asking okay what would you
call them then
population population or so just the
population of the world of the country
or whatever of the other people people
and then on the other end then you
someone has to pay for this someone has
paid for that and so for the most part
this is insurers yep insurance companies
in in the old days like if you go back a
hundred years we didn't really have
insurers we had patients and and
providers and patients would if they had
a question they had a concern they go to
the provider they'd make some deal pay
them some money do some service for them
and work it out
right we got insurance companies really
only in the last 100 years maybe really
starting in the u.s and maybe 1930 1940
they started to become popular so that's
kind of a new renovation and those three
things work together and the general
term and this is the word i've seen a
lot and sometimes a little confusing
because it's very close to payer it's
not you you hear that kind of these pay
yours
yeah pay yours and that that would be
including that's anyone who's paying for
the paying for the service yeah
insurance companies would be included
there right so we have we call them pay
payer sometimes we call them health
plans because they arrange for some of
the care that people get and you know
payers could be private private
companies private insurance companies or
they could be government rights
government insurance companies like
medicare and the insurance companies
themselves they're not doing this you
know just out of the goodness of their
heart someone is paying them right and
for the most part in the united states
it tends to be employers so right so
we've we made another arrow on your
diagram here it would be
from the population or maybe from the
patients to the insurance companies that
provides the money for the insurance
companies to use to pay for the provider
so patients might buy an insurance
company or buy an insurance company
buying insurance people live there very
well some of them buy the whole thing a
few right but um patients might buy
their own policy go buy an insurance
policy pay them a premium directly right
make sure somebody collects that money
or for most people they work for an
employer the employer makes the
arrangement to buy that insurance
and then implicitly charges the
population the patients for that maybe
directly by having them contribute some
of their salary maybe implicitly by just
reducing the amount of cash they give
them every month and instead giving them
this insurance
so people do that and the other piece
that's floating around in here is that
in some cases the population pays taxes
to the government oh right that then
that then functions essentially as an
insurer like the medicare program where
there's uh insurance provided to people
it's paid for by taxes so there's some
different funds flows going around here
but always money going from patients to
insurers through employers through taxes
by direct payments those insurers
collecting the money and then paying for
a bunch of the care that's provided by
the providers right and that's the basic
arrangement there's one more tiny piece
which is that sometimes patients pay the
doctors or the hospitals directly yeah
you go you have a 20 copayment right and
so there's a small payment that goes
back and forth right your copay is kind
of there just so that it kind of makes
the insurance company feel good that
you're not just using it willy-nilly
that you have to pay your you know
whatever ten dollars or fifty dollars
absolutely so insurers know that once
they start paying the providers for the
care and the patient says it's totally
free people might use stuff that you
know it might be worth a little tiny bit
but it costs a lot for everybody to pay
for so if you put a co-payment on there
makes people think twice about using
things that they don't really need very
much right that makes complete sense and
then within this ecosystem you know we
hear a lot about hmos uh that at my
perception is that's a combination of
the insurance company and the providers
kind of in one
package right so over time the us has
had different kinds of insurers out
there in the private market especially
there's been a lot of innovation in the
last 30 40 years and types of insurers
that are out there so we have different
insurers that
have behaved in different ways as we've
gone through those evolutionary cycles
so one version of that is what we call
an hmo a health maintenance organization
and that's really just jargon you have
to dig into it to figure out what it
means but in a lot of cases what that is
is an insur a company that's acting as
insurance so you pay a premium to them
if you're a patient right or a person
and you buy some coverage and then
they'll cover your care but they'll do
that by trying to integrate themselves
with the providers right so the
organizations either are integrated
because the hmo hires doctors directly
or maybe owns the hospitals like kaiser
permanente for example right or in some
cases it's a contractual relationship
it's not exactly the same so not omar is
tightly linked to like a kaiser where
it's like you go you go to this building
that says kaiser on it and that's where
your doctor is it could be doctors just
have their practices but they're tightly
linked with a i think that's how one
blue shield or one of those yeah blue
shield or aetna or some of these
different companies uh and you can start
to dig into the details and everyone
will be a little bit different right
from the other but they're contractual
relationships and the difference and i
think this is something everyone faces
when they you know sign up insurance
with their employer i had to do it
recently is you know they always say you
have to pick hmo versus
versus ppo and they're within the same
policy and so my perception is hmo is
uh
they they you have a you have a set list
of doctors that i'm they've probably
pre-negotiated pricing with yeah so the
difference between hmos and ppos gets um
it gets a little bit into the uh
sort of think about it in the way that
you're talking about it so an hmo will
have a list of doctors that you're
supposed to see and you'll have to go
see doctors on that list and the
stereotypical one if you don't see the
doctors on that list uh the insurance
company is not going to pay for your
care you're going to pay yourself and in
a stereotypical hmo there's going to be
a fairly tight management between the
insurance company and the doctors about
what's going to be done what's allowable
and so on and the most tightly linked
case they'll be like the same
they'll be
employed by the company right that's
like right kaiser as you kind of think
about it as a spectrum if you move a
little bit away from that to a ppo
what's happening in pp is you're still
going to get a list right so you're
going to be encouraged to see those
doctors but maybe there'll be a little
more flexibility like if you decided not
to see someone on the list the plan
would still pay some amount maybe not as
much as they would if you saw someone on
a list but something whereas in an hmo
maybe nothing and the plan will probably
work a little less hard at managing what
those doctors are doing to try and limit
access to say high cost services hmo
tend to work harder ppo tends to work a
little less hard so it's a little bit of
a spectrum you're kind of moving from
more managed and more concentrated uh to
a little less managed but still more so
than the system we had say in the 50s or
60s where anybody went to any doctor and
any doctor did whatever they wanted and
the insurance company just paid the bill
and there was no integration so it's a
little bit of fun so that's the main
motivation why insurance companies are
trying to get kind of more more
integrated with the providers is because
just like you said in the 50s and 60s
you have the provider providing a
service and obviously the patient would
like the service and then you have a
third party paying for it and so there's
no check on you know the person deciding
on the service the person getting it
says yeah let's get more service and
someone else is is right right so that's
just so we created a big issue insurance
companies are kind of an interesting
thing in a health policy world because
we we have to have them right we have to
have them to manage the risk associated
with getting sick you get sick today and
get a huge bill and so we can't leave
people on their own for that we've got
to have insurance companies but as soon
as you create insurance companies and i
can have implicitly all my neighbors pay
for the health care that i want right
then i might start using things that uh
turn out to be inefficient and so you
gotta you gotta have them insurance
companies but
you gotta manage what happens when you
have them also and so that's the
integration between providers or
co-payments and utilization review and
all these things are basically attempts
by insurance companies to try and manage
what economists would call the moral
hazard that you using additional
services that you don't necessarily need
because everybody else is going to pay
for it for you that makes makes complete
sense oh thanks that makes a ton of
sense